[Music]
Helicopter Surveillance video and body
camera images show a suspected car
thief's arrest in Atlanta Georgia
it happened on November 11th in
Southeast Atlanta body camera video
shows a police officer pull over a
vehicle for not having valid tags or
Insurance when the officer approached
the vehicle they smelled marijuana and
saw what appeared to be a gun inside
after that the SUV sped off
investigators later determined the
vehicle was stolen from neighboring
Alabama
foreign
when the suspect drove off Atlanta
police deployed its air and canine units
to search for him a helicopter crew
eventually found him hiding behind a
house
APD officers Tracked Down The Suspect
and ordered him to stop and get on the
ground
get off the ground get on the ground
[Applause]
here on time
eventually officers caught up with the
suspect and placed him under arrest
Atlanta police identified the suspect as
Relic Robinson who was later booked in
the Fulton County jail he's now facing
multiple charges including theft by
receiving stolen property possession of
a firearm by a convicted felon
possession of marijuana less than an
ounce possession of a controlled
substance fleeing and eluding and
obstruction of justice investigators are
still searching for the two other men
involved in the incident for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie